[Music]
this is
the ramsey show you can be intentional
about your character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as
the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host
kristy wright ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today as we talk about your life
and your money it's a free call and some
say the advice is worth
exactly what you pay for it the phone
number triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight
eight two five five two two five
david is with us in baton rouge to start
off this hour hi david how are you
good dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
so me and my wife um we are running into
a little bit of an issue actually teach
your class to high school students
awesome yes and so i am
really trying to follow you by the book
by the t
but what we're running into right now is
i make 26.50
a month take home pay we have eleven
thousand dollars in savings and my wife
just graduated with her master's
in speech therapy in may and she
brought in 20 000 in student loans with
that
now i know your step-by-step says to
take 10 000 of our 11 000 and throw it
towards the debt
but we are expecting in the next two
weeks
all right first child good well you're
not you're not working the baby steps
then you push pause
on the baby steps you don't push play
until baby comes and mommy comes and
home and everybody's healthy and
everybody's okay but yeah you you would
not be
paying down debt uh during the pregnancy
okay
okay so yeah we were planning on setting
aside um
10 000 to the separate savings account
and attacking it fairly aggressively um
but it's still there if we need it and
so we're not
well you won't need it once you need it
once the baby comes home
if the baby comes home and mommy and
baby are okay why would you why would
you need to do that
okay yeah that makes sense but if
everybody's not okay you got the money
right now
you know you cover the emergency that's
what it's for right now but if you're
gonna once they come home and
is she going on into speech therapy once
uh you know six or eight weeks or
whatever from now
yeah we're playing that by ear we're not
sure exactly when she's gonna start
working but i'm hoping in the next
uh you know few months after the baby
comes home
that she's gonna start getting into work
is she gonna work somewhere for a
practice or a company or she gonna do
her own thing
no she's gonna be working for a practice
okay good well she already had to find
stuff and they're
being very uh generous with when she can
start
oh that's wonderful good well she ought
to make really good money with that
degree and
that's a wonderful field and both of you
are in great fields and so
um you know if you want to hold it until
she goes back to work that's
okay you know but the bottom line is is
really a having a baby
that's healthy and everything's going
okay it becomes part of your budget then
uh whether it's daycare or formula or
diapers and
uh christy i mean obviously i got not i
got
the seventh grand baby will be here any
minute and and you've got little babes
little kids so um you know the the truth
is is that your budget doesn't other
than daycare your budget does not
change that substantially diapers a
little bit for me a little bit but
it's not like thousands of dollars a
month out of your budget just because
you had a baby no and what's interesting
is
after a couple months of living on this
new budget with a baby it gives you a
sense of confidence of knowing that
you can i think it's the unknown that's
scary to especially to new parents going
oh my gosh how much are diapers how much
is formula how much is all this okay
give yourself a couple months just like
when you set your budget the first time
you are learning what this is like it's
going to be just like that and sure
it'll change a little bit especially if
your white
wife goes back to work and daycare and
all that but you work it into the budget
you live the budget a few months and
tweak it as necessary and then before
you know it like oh this is just our new
normal
with our family of three which is great
and it's not as scary
because it's no longer unknown yeah and
the little critters are not as expensive
as everybody carries home
and i mean they're not they're they're
expensive but it's not it doesn't break
the bank
it's not like 200 000 a year or
something no and rachel cruz talks about
this but you don't need
all the things the the list of things
you could get for the baby
is infinite and you will learn what you
actually need and what you actually use
and what you actually
want and then everything else you can
let go so it's just gonna take a couple
months to figure that out and that's
okay
yeah yeah good stuff man congratulations
yeah congratulations that's wonderful
that's awesome
uh christina is in el paso hi christina
welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave thank you for taking my car i
really appreciate it sure
how can christy and i help yes so my
question is um
my uh two four-year-old twins are
getting ready to start school and i
wanted to
you know get in a career to be able to
help my husband out
so we could get out of debt and i wanted
to know if it would be a good idea
to invest in a career as a real estate
agent in this market
right now what's drawing you to that
well i mean i really want to be able to
help out my husband um he's the only one
working right now
and he's basically bringing home yeah
but why real estate
oh real estate well um i was
thinking it would be good money
and basically i went to school for
cosmetology
when i was out of high school and that
didn't really bring in
that much money and we do have a lot of
debt and
we're just trying to get out of it quick
and
um you know look into a brighter future
soon
it's just we we barely started our our
debt snowball
and we just want to you know get out of
it as quickly as
possible christina i hear that and
that's that's a
a noble thing to want i will encourage
you that there are a lot of career paths
that can make good money and you're
going to need to want more than money
to be really good at it and to stick
with it for the long haul so i think it
goes back to dave's question why
real estate is it is there anything else
that draws you to that particular field
other than money because it's gonna need
it's gonna need more than money to
sustain you especially real estate can
be hard and there's some upfront costs
and that kind of thing so
when you think about what you want to do
you work when other people are off
yeah weekends nights so think about what
you want to do
yes well i did want to you know
you focus in my career but it's just
that
i recently got diagnosed with arthritis
and basically what i was doing was a
nail technician and that's just too much
on my hands now
but i you know i am interested in
selling
houses and it looks like a bright future
to me
but well real estate's really hot right
now that's not in question i mean
obviously you could get into the
business
um it's very difficult because there's
not much inventory
to make a quick sale you know
we're hearing multiple offers and all
the offers are over
asking price and so the few listings
that are out there go rather quickly and
rather competitively which is tough for
a brand new agent
uh but it can be done i mean uh you're
gonna have
a a few dry months you're gonna work
for two months or three months or four
months with no money
coming in and are you if you're prepared
to do that
that's okay it's a wonderful career i've
had my real estate license since i was
18 years old i've not been practicing in
the business but
other than as an investor in a long time
but
you can do it if you want to do it if
you just think it's quick easy money
uh it's not it's not it's not quick and
it's not easy
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online
ordering free shipping and a guaranteed
perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
825-5225
marissa is with us in trenton hi marissa
how are you
hi thank you so much for taking my call
sure what's up
so i am 29 years old i have been working
as a nurse for the last six years i am a
single mom
my daughter is six years old and i made
the
big financial commitment to go back to
nurse anesthesia school
wow so yes i paid off my undergraduate
loan which was 30
000 my parents did help me and support
me through the way
um that was paid before going into
school as well as my car and i have no
credit card debt
the school now will cost me about
250 000 and with interest it'll be about
300 000
um i've been with my boyfriend for about
four years and besides paying back the
loan we're looking
to get married in the next few years and
have
more kids so i just wanted to see what
your thoughts were on coming up with a
plan i think i could realistically pay
off
this almost 300 000 in the next three to
five years
but it's very daunting and i don't know
how to balance that with
having a wife getting married and having
more kids at the same time
okay um you've been listening to us not
a long time i take it
for the past few months my boyfriend
actually um turned me onto the show and
i've been listening
few a few hours every single day i just
don't know how to make the baby steps
really work for me
i staged 30 000 to live on
for the three years that i'm in school
yeah
okay um
well to start with let's pretend that
you had already graduated and you had
this loan
you would have you'd be making how much
three hundred thousand a year right
two hundred thousand a year where um
we're on training i would start at 205.
okay and you make what now
i actually just stopped working because
what were you making when you just
stopped working
i was making 75 okay all right which
makes a
difference of 140 000 so you could be
you could pay off 300 000
in two years if you continue to live
like you were living right before you
stopped working
yeah which would be what i would tell
you to do
were you already here but you're not
already here
in 30 years of doing this show i've
never told anyone to go into debt to go
to school and i'm not going to start
today
so i'm mr dream killer today i
love the idea of you being a nurse
anesthetist
i love the idea of your income going
from 75 to 205 and i think those are
accurate numbers by the way i don't
think you're living in a dream world i
think that's about right based on what i
the number of nurse anesthetists i have
coached over the years
and by the way i think i think 205 is
this floor i think that's starting i
think it'll head towards 300 pretty
quick
especially if you pick up ot and other
things you could knock that debt out
very quickly
the problem comes into play in that
you're talking to a guy
who has coached people where this plan
didn't work
that your mother
became ill your child became ill you
became ill
there was a car wreck there was
something and you're
200 000 into this and you don't complete
or you get married you have more babies
and you want to stay home
and you don't want to work at all which
you don't know what you're going to want
in three years or five years with a
different family and situation but you
have that debt anyway
i just want to clarify i'm actually in
the program already i'm in the second
year of the program
oh so you've already taken that loan
that was not what you said
yeah i'm confused you've already taken
out the loan for the program you're
you're in it
i'm in it i'm in the second year so
we're living off my boyfriend's income
he makes
90 000 by the time i'm finished he'll
make 130
000 um so i'm not paying for living
expenses right now i'm living off my
savings
and we're planning when i graduate to
put all of my paychecks towards the loan
and he continues to pay for living okay
when are y'all getting married that's
the thing
um i think he he says we
probably would have been doing that now
we really push everything off
because of my going back to school
taking out this
why are you going back to school keep
you from getting married
you just go down and get married
we want a really small wedding okay then
just go get married
go tomorrow
what's this painter get off the ladder
yeah and we're renting right now i don't
know what's that got to do with it
renters get married all the time
yeah i just feel guilty i don't have any
money to put towards a wedding or a
house
whether you're married or not you have
nothing to feel guilty about you're
playing house you might as well get a
piece of paper that says it's okay
it's gonna bring a different level of
being a team and attacking these
financial goals together when you're
really
afraid for you i mean if he decides to
walk off there's nothing
if he decides to walk off yours or
you're screwed
i i could live with my my parents if if
i had to
you kind of missed the point didn't you
oh you mean with paying back the loan
okay
so um i i i don't know what the question
is now i think you're
i think you have your plan and i guess
you need to execute your plan uh it
would be a different plan than christie
and i would sign you up for
we hope good things for you we want good
things for you we're not mad at you we
don't want anything but
to come to you but blessings but um yeah
i the these plans of going this far into
debt to get a
valid degree with a great income like
becoming an attorney or becoming a
medical doctor or becoming a nurse
anesthetist
they only work when they work
but the guy that didn't pass the bar
four times will tell you
that that 185 000 worth of law school
debt is not a freaking guarantee
so i i just i worry for you kid i just
don't want bad things to happen for you
i hope it all works out i hope it all
plays through
i hope you come out making 205 he's
making 135 and he finally gets around to
marrying you or you finally get around
to marrying him
and then you've got a 340 000 or 50 000
household income and you pay off this
300 in like
one year 18 months 24 months that's what
i would do
but um you know i if that's your
question yeah that's what i would do i
would attack it like a vengeance and the
first thing you need to do is quit
borrowing
if he's got enough income coming in and
you're sharing income as if you're
married i wouldn't recommend that
but apparently that's what you're doing
so then maybe if he's got 130 coming in
maybe you don't have to take borrows a
dadgum much
if you're married it'd be no question
that would be what you should do
i'm not sure he should pay for his
girlfriend's education though
matter of fact i'm sure he shouldn't let
me try that again i've never told
anybody do that either
so i get so confused
you're like what what am i saying what
question are what have i committed to
what have i
signed up for how did we get here man
i'm just oh okay so um
here's the deal let's backtrack a second
because we have about a minute before
the break
so let's say you're out there and you're
facing this exact dilemma
the mountainous amount of tuition
to get a an equal mountainous amount of
income if it all works out perfectly
and sometimes it does admittedly but it
doesn't always we all have to admit that
and we can't act like it's 100
right it's a lock it's not a lock
doesn't always happen
maybe there's another way to get at this
maybe you're working for a hospital
company who wants you to commit
to being their nurse anesthetist which
they're recruiting for and having
trouble getting right now
and you promise to stay there three
years in return
they promise to pay your tuition and you
probably you don't go ahead and lock
down a
contractual rate at which you're willing
to work um
that way you don't have any debt so the
ways around it you know or
maybe you get a fellowship and you're
working a fellowship
at a mid school and you're teaching grad
classes and other things while you're
doing this
and you get through it yeah maybe you
work overtime like crazy as a nurse and
pile up lots and lots and lots of money
and you pay cash for
your education but it takes you three
years longer and you don't have all the
risk
these are the things we would tell
someone facing similar situations to do
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over 70 a month
by switching
to pure top just go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo
code ramsey to save 50 off your first
month
pure talk simply smarter wireless
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five so christy has a passion
for the topic of life balance
and it's not a subject that i have
particularly loved
talking about uh because i think
sometimes it's code for
uh i don't want to work much and uh
yet you've hit a nerve talking about
this and you found a way to talk about
it that um
that you and i are both excited about
yes
you and i love to debate and this is a
topic that we have loved to debate about
for the last decade but we have found
a common ground and i think the thing
that frustrates both you and i is the
way that it's misunderstood
as if somehow we are all seeking this
perfect 50
50 split in our life or we're gonna do
everything for an equal amount of time
we're gonna have
you know 15 minutes of quiet time and 15
minutes of exercise and 15 minutes
none of that is realistic or even
desirable and so as i have been
researching this coaching people for you
know years and years and certainly
trying to create in my own life with
three kids in five years and
working and traveling and so on i just
started asking a different question
instead of asking how do i balance it
all
i started asking what if we could create
a sense of balance even in our busy
lives
and where does that come from and what
does that look like in a practical
tactical way
versus always feeling guilty all the
time no matter what we do and it sent me
on this search
that i think is really helpful not just
for people that need more time or feel
like they want more hours in a day
it's even helpful for the person
listening that's trying to pay off their
debt
that is focusing intensely in this
season of life being gazelle intense and
saying these are my priorities
it helps you understand hey where your
money goes where your time goes when you
can control those
you've got a pretty good handle on how
you're spending your life and and and
they correlate more than we realize
yeah it's you you always say you don't
find time you make time
you make time for what's important to
you and um
you know that that's been kind of my
thing with this life balance thing
it's just so because the people that i
know that are successful
at anything are not balanced yeah
evenly right they're not doing
everything everything equally
uh at any given time whatever you're i
mean if you're a successful parent
you are out of balance you spend uh the
your children are a priority
and they should be okay if you have a
successful marriage
your marriage is a priority yeah um
probably not uh you know memorizing
every football statistic
of college football in the fall yeah
which i love college football but i've
never done that
but i mean i know football widows and
it's not because their husband is a
a coach and it's not because their
husband's a player it's because his butt
is on the couch
that's out that's and that's out of
balance but it's really not what it is
is prioritizing the wrong things
it is and you know this this idea of
priorities is
interesting because when we say
priorities we talk about it as if we
have
one set of priorities that are fixed and
they are in concrete these are my
priorities
god other self and that that's real that
sounds like a nice sunday school answer
that's not practical in any given season
you will say
okay in this season i'm all in game on
at work or i'm
you know it's the summer i'm going to
take some vacation i'm going to play
with my kids in this season i'm training
for a marathon my exercise is a higher
priority
within each season you're going to have
a more specific more current
relevant practical tactical set of
priorities and you
should yeah now if you don't do anything
except work
seven days a week for six years and you
don't know your kids names
that's not the top priority that's not
okay it is a priority but it's a wrong
one
yeah there should be an ebb and flow and
i think the the the thesis that i have
unpacked in my book coming out this fall
is life balance is not doing
everything for an equal amount of time
it's doing the right things
at the right time and when you do the
right things at the right time whatever
that is
you feel that sense of balance you've
been looking for because when it's game
on at work
it's game one at work when it's time to
go on vacation i'm putting my phone away
i'm gonna play in the beach and be with
my kids but when you can
focus on the right things at the right
time it gives you permission to not only
actually experience your life but enjoy
it and be proud of how you're spending
your time
finally all the time intentionally pay a
price to win so
i just thought of it the reason i've
been frustrated with the other version
of life oh i'm so ready for this
i just figured it out i never thought
about it all these times we've been
arguing about it
um was if you live like no one else yeah
later you can live and give like no one
else
is in conflict with this
evenly yeah perfectly balanced right
nurturing focus
because then i get people to call me up
and go my poor children will never see
their father
oh for six months because you work
okay get your butt up and work yeah and
you know
and i'm not saying you never see them
but you work a bunch of ot for six
months why
so you change the rest of your life with
your children right that's what i did
right and my children aren't in
counseling right they're they're not in
rehab centers right
they're all walking with jesus they're
all married and got kids you know i mean
they all made it out of old days working
and work you know was not a
singular priority but there were seasons
that we had to do we had to do what it
took to go in right and so so a very
practical thing i tell people to ask
themselves is this and you can start
this right now today if you're watching
or listening
what's right right now what's right
right now what's right right now
okay there's a million things i could be
doing what's right right now i'm on the
i'm on the ramsay show that's what's
right right now i could be thinking
about kids what
i would actually be concentrating right
right now when i'm at home
and my kids are trying to show me what
they you know what they did at school or
tell me
what's right right there i'm gonna focus
on them what's right right now and it
gives you permission to not say
you don't have a lot going on you always
have a lot going on what's right right
now this thing i'm going to focus on
this i'm going to be present here
and then in any given season or week or
day as your priorities shift
you give yourself permission to shift
and adapt and change them
with the changing seasons yeah i mean my
son just did one of these spartan races
and so
and he's got a new he's got a new baby
on the way yep so he you know his
workout was really extreme he goes i'm
getting this
thing knocked out while your baby comes
because once baby comes there's no sleep
and i'm not i know this because my
sisters have babies and so that's what
he's saying
right and so i've got to go you know but
that's right right now
uh four months from now that won't be
right anymore right
yeah and he's got a whole different set
of priorities right um you know what
and should exactly and what's
interesting is when you have things you
want to do with your money or your time
this is so in alignment with what we
teach about money
but when you have things you want to do
but it's not right right now
it helps you let go of that temporarily
because you're not saying oh that dream
has died forever
nursing let's go back to nurse genesis
it's not oh that's not never
it's just not right now yeah it's not
whatever whatever that thing is for you
whether it's a
something you want to buy somewhere you
want to go so you know there's things
i'd love to go to europe with my husband
matt
when i got three little babies that's
not right right now we'll go someday but
right right now i don't want to be away
from my babies for two weeks okay
what's right right now it gives you
permission to say yes what's right right
now
and know that something that may come
back around at a different time when
it's right then and that's okay
yeah and that happens so if you have
this sense of being overwhelmed
this sense of anxiety you know we're
getting over into dr dalony's area
because there's so many things pulling
at you yeah
that's a good way of clearing it out not
everything pulling at you
is right right now
and that you know i've noticed this with
generosity
you know we budget an amount going into
the ramsey family foundation did you
know that there's
always more good things that we can
spend that on than there is money
that we could invest in in god's name
than there is money
there's always more good happening in
the world than the ramsey family
foundation can finance
we have a tiny little sliver of the
world yeah that we're supposed to take
care of and help with that
and the rest of them get a no because
it's not right
though we're gonna pick the ones that
are right right now it's still it's
prioritizing your money prioritizing
your time
yep exactly right yeah that's powerful
that's good stuff
are we are we revealing the book title
yet
yeah what let's just decide yeah we're
yeah let's do it it's yours you can
decide
we'll do it so we've we've been working
on this
for a long time and it's really cool to
see how all of the
uh stories i've heard have really led to
this so the book
launches for pre-sale july 12th and it
is titled
dramaal take back your time
the guilt-free guide to life balance
guilt-free let's get rid of that guilt
take back your time
take there's so much action in that you
know i love that
take it back take it back take back your
time
i love it so if you uh want more tips
and encouragement about life balance for
free christy wright will participate
with you in that just text her
text life balance 233 444
text life balance to 33
[Music]
[Applause]
444.
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chrissy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five dan is in iowa city iowa hi
dan how are you
veteran i deserve days how are you just
the same sir what's up awesome first i
just wanted to say
thank you to you and christy for
everything you guys do you guys are so
awesome and such an inspiration so i
really appreciate you guys
thank you for saying that
my question today dave is about early
retirement so for background context i'm
24.
my annual income is about 37 000 a year
i have no debt my car's paid for and i
heard you say
you know a couple times that when you
before you get married when you buy a
house
and then you get married you realize you
bought the wrong house yeah so i don't
know when i'm getting married
but i wanted to call in and see like
what what would you prioritize in my
situation would you prioritize early
retirement if
if the goal was reachable in say five
years or would you put the money in a
mutual fund
towards a sizable down payment or
preferably a
a cash purchase on a home a small home
[Music]
okay let's go back a second because
you're 24
and early retirement is in five years so
you're from 29 years old on
for the rest of your life what are you
going to do
i would like to start my own company um
i want to do something
in e-commerce that um sort of like
is my ministry tool i'm a part-time
photographer outdoor photographer
and i you know a lot of my friends like
98
of my friends okay so by retirement you
don't mean go fishing
by retirement you mean and you don't
have to work a regular job and you can
go live your dream of owning your own
business
yeah exactly just financial freedom and
just supplemental income from
investments
gotcha okay all right good
um well i think you can start making
moves towards that
now i don't think that requires that you
be financially independent
a lot of people don't right as a matter
of fact it might be your
shortest path to financial independence
because if you got your business up and
running you might make more than thirty
seven thousand dollars
that's true yeah
yeah what made me ask the question dave
is because um i
i listen every day and have for about a
year now and
um i'm on i'm on baby step i guess you'd
say i guess you'd say four
um so i've been investing fifteen
percent
um but wanted to know like okay what do
i prioritize because my expenses are so
low
yeah so like rent aside um my my yearly
expenses dave are only two thousand
dollars a year
that's why um just with my my only bills
are car insurance
phone so you're living at home that's
really
it um no so i just
i usually i move around a lot so my rent
is kind of
hard to say like what it is for a full
year but it's usually between
350 and 450 and so that's more than 2
000
a year
yeah i just wanted to do retirement just
so i could like
um basically set up early retirement so
that when i'm in the place where i
don't have a rent or mortgage payment um
i i would be able to focus on that okay
let's let's
change the word from retirement to you
just want to build some wealth
okay sure and um so i think you can
begin to work on your new idea for your
business as a side hustle
don't you christy yeah sure start that
now you're gonna learn a lot in the
process you don't have to wait till some
magic five years from now or certain
income to be able to do it start now
and learn about what you want to do and
what the market needs yeah let's get
that going and let's
um uh uh you know start that and
and get your income up and when the
income gets close to what you make now
go ahead and start working
and living your dream don't wait until
you have a pile of money to go live your
dream
it's not necessary um sure i
i haven't i started two businesses both
of which were very successful one of
which failed later my real estate
business
but i started both of them with
literally nothing um
and got started so you can do that now
and ease into this and organically let
you can take all the money you make in
the business pour it back into the
business
and just live off of your day job and
that's fine until you get the thing up
and running
um and so if that's working
then that doesn't require any investing
then we can say oh let's redirect all
your cash towards paying cash for your
first house
and that's probably what i would do at
that point i would just go that
direction
so uh because you know and then if you
do buy a house and it's the wrong one
you can sell it another one if you get
married all that kind of that joke and
all that stuff that we talk about but
it's joke based in fact but um but the
uh uh but yeah that's that's
you know i i i don't think that you need
a half a million dollars
in a paid for house in order to start
your business you know what's
interesting is you know he's young
asking this question and it's actually
similar to what we were just talking
about before the break where
your priorities change and when you're
young and you
you have a small sense of what you want
to do but you can't predict the future
none of us can you can say okay what do
i want to do based on what i know today
based on what i know today is i want to
build wealth i want to start a business
let's start it on the side
i'd like to get married but i'm not
dating anybody i'd like to buy a house
but i don't have the money yet
so let's just do what we can do today
with what we know today what we have
today
that's one of your phrases you said
earlier what's right right now right and
then in three years five years get
married by house what's right then
good robertson san antonio hey robert
how are you
hey dave's doing great how are you
better than i deserve what's up
that's what i thought hey listen i got a
business decision
i've got to make i'm 66 years old i've
got a business
that um having some offers on and i'm a
veterinarian
and some of these corporate run uh some
of these corporations
buy veterinary clinics offer three to
three and a half times the gross
and that doesn't include real estate now
i don't have any sort of money i'm in
pretty good shape
i just don't know if i should sell or
not
well what's the long term plan if you
don't
i'm just going to keep on working till
when you're gone
what happens to it when you die until
the day they bear me i'm gonna keep
working
okay what happens when you die what
happens what happens
then go to my wife grant my kids yeah
and then they sell it for three times
gross
i'm sure they'll just appreciate their
value yeah okay
so what's the pressure to sell it now i
don't hear any
well i mean it's a lot of money and
sometimes i get locked into just
my life and working and all my hobbies
and things
and i i don't look you know and that's
why i need a different perspective
yeah well i i will you know
it sounds to me like you would have some
joy stolen from you
if you weren't working down there oh
yeah
that's that's what's happening go ahead
go ahead
you go ahead well the hard part robert
is sometimes people call in and this is
a similar
question where you can do either but we
can't tell you what you want
and it kind of comes down to what do you
want you're 66 years old
what do you want i think you want to
work it another 10 years anyway that's
what i think just listening to you
i want to keep working and fingers if i
sell the damn thing i'd have to work for
the corporations yeah
no thanks you don't want to do that no
thank you
you've done this yourself too long this
is your baby let me uh let me tell you
here's what i would do before you make
the decision i think this will answer
your question
order a book when you hang up uh you can
jump on amazon or whatever
from simon sinek the book is called
infinite game
yeah what you're being tempted by is a
finite game
and putting closure on this and turning
the key
and the infinite game is you just keep
playing
and that's that's the temptation that's
in front of you um
and there's something in our culture
that says if you don't take the uh
take the cash off the table while the
hand is hot
that you've done something wrong and
i've got good friends i have a good
friend that sold this business for 400
million dollars and the last time i was
with him he cried
he hates his life he works for this
publicly traded company now
and they he said i hate my life i would
give them
an extra 50 million on top of the 400
million if i could buy the thing back
and let me have my soul back
that was his comment and i kind of think
i'm hearing a little bit of that in your
discussion
i got a question dave about about the
terms of something like this because
is it always the case where uh in
robert's case or your friend's case
where you have to work in the business
or can you sell it and walk
you could sell it and walk but they
probably want him to stay a while
because you're probably a big part of
the secret sauce of that one
yeah yeah oh yeah i'm part of the recipe
i think you're not going to want to be
wanting to work for a corporation i'm
just listening to you
i'm not telling you what i would do i
know what i would do i wouldn't work for
him
but uh um and so i i do think
you need a long-term handoff that's
better than
tossing the keys as you fall back into
the grave that's not a good handoff
but but i don't know that you're ready
to sell it and work for a corporation
for 10 more years either
so somewhere in between there is
probably a better plan
hybrid but read that book infinite game
by my friend simon i think you'll like
it
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network
app on your smartphone browse by topic
or even sync clips to your friends
download the ramsay network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host thank you for joining
us christy wright ramsey personality is
my co-host open phones at triple eight
eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight
eight two five five two two
five james is with us to start off this
hour
james is in wilmington north carolina hi
james how are you
hi dave good yourself better than i
deserve what's up
awesome um so i was
curious i'm 38 married um
and uh my 401 is about a little over 600
000
and i didn't know if i should borrow
from it to pay off my house and or
car no no
okay i would stop adding to it
stop adding to it temporarily until you
get your car paid off
even if the company matches even if the
company match
you need to get your car paid off how
much do you own your car
uh just bought it to 32. and you
borrowed all of that
what's that yes do you have any money no
no i haven't borrowed it i haven't
borrowed it uh
i thought you said borrow against your
401k to pay off your car
if i should borrow against my 401 to pay
it off
yeah so have you do you owe money on
your car
yes 32 000 you borrowed money on the car
that's what i was talking about
so how much money do you have uh i have
about
3 000 in savings and 10 000 for like an
emergency
mm-hmm okay
well james we teach a process that is
the shortest distance between where you
are
and wealth you've done an extremely good
job
with your investing you've done a very
poor job
with some of the other areas of your
money so you're way ahead on investing
in your way behind
on some of the other things your goal
should be to be debt free
not counting your house and have an
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses
before you start investing so we're
temporarily going to stop investing
temporarily i want you to hold one
thousand dollars back as a beginner
starter emergency fund
and i want you to throw everything else
at the car what do you make
uh my base salary is 71.5
but with overtime usually about 90 a
year
okay so how quick if we throw ten
thousand dollars at this car
or twelve thousand dollars at this car
how quickly are you uh
gonna knock out the other twenty
thousand like
six months yeah possibly yeah
just depends on my wife's business too
so okay
good oh i'm sorry i didn't ask what she
made but what does she make okay
uh she makes she pays herself twelve
thousand for her base salary
and then it just uh all the clients her
practice
see so it kind of varies well russell
roughly what does she make a year
taxable income oh i have no idea
more than me more than 90.
yes okay yeah then you should pay off
the car within a month or two
or three something like that and then
you need the baby step
three build an emergency fund of three
to six months of expenses
and then you would start putting 15
percent of your income away towards
retirement
that's baby step four five is start
saving for kids college if that's
applicable in your situation and six is
we begin to any other money we can be
beyond fifteen percent of your income
that you can find any other money you
can get your hands on i would get the
house paid off early and that walks you
right up what we call our baby steps
they're outlined in in my best-selling
book called the total money makeover
i'll give you a copy of it
hold on kelly will pick up and we'll
send you a copy of the total money
makeover it shows you exactly
how to work the baby steps exactly what
to do
sarah is in tennessee hi sarah your
question for christy and me
all right so i am 16 years old i just
graduated high school
and i want to start my own photography
business hopefully at the
end of the beginning of next year and i
was wondering
how much money should i take and spend
towards
starting my business up sarah that's
awesome you're 16 and just graduated
yeah okay well congratulations that's
amazing
early so you're like one of those smart
kids one of those go-getters
that's awesome that's awesome well let
me ask you a couple
really basic questions because this is
not uh it's not super complicated
doesn't have to be
do you have a camera oh yeah i do
okay but i'm gonna need to upgrade it so
i was just wondering what's a reasonable
amount of money to spend towards all
upgrading and stuff well do you know
uh photoshop lighting do you know the
basics of how to take photos you know
the basics
how do you kind of work it okay so
here's what i want you to do sarah
you can start your business now with the
camera that you have
jeremy jeremy cowart who is one of the
world renowned photographers started
with a three megapixel digital camera
that's like a hundred dollars
you can start with what you have and use
the cash
that you get from these photo sessions
to
save uh for a better camera but you
don't need to have that upfront cost to
get your business started because you
have a camera
that works and you know how to use it
you can use that
now and then just set aside a percentage
of your money
decide what that is you probably don't
have any expenses except most of it if
you want
and save up and get you a better camera
but i don't want you to feel like you
have to wait uh to have a better camera
to start you can start right now with
what you have
way to go that's awesome what's your
long-term plan what do you want to be
doing when you're 29
uh photography hopefully okay you're
just going to continue to build this
business
and study photography and build it and
study photography and build it
yeah good for you hey sarah i would love
to send you a copy of my book business
boutique it's a real easy read you can
even skip around if you don't want to
read the whole thing but one of the
things i talk about there in the book
that's super important for you is word
of mouth marketing
because a photography business is a
referral based businesses people want to
get photos from someone
that took their friends photos and did a
good job so stay on the line and kelly
can send you a copy of my book and you
can check out learn a little bit about
how to
incentivize that activate your customers
to talk about your business for you to
get even more
clients to grow your business but well
done that's awesome that's really really
cool
she graduated from high school a year
and a half early it doesn't have to be
an easy rate
she can have no she she's going to she
can take this she can handle it she can
handle your books she can handle any
book i wrote she can handle it she's
going to make it fly this one's going to
be okay she's driven
so yeah sarah the only other thing i
would add is just cont be a continual
learner
because i can promise you uh in the last
10 years the photography world has
changed to the technology world
um it's it's moved dramatically in 10
years
to the point that most of us carry
around in the version of our cell phone
a camera that is much nicer than
professional photographers used 10 years
ago
and uh the little three-eyed iphone is a
beast of a camera
and um and so is the you know the google
phones and all the you know
these things the cameras that these
things have in them are ridiculous so
stay on top of the technology stay on
top of photography continue to
take classes be an apprentice shadow
people
yeah shadow hang out with in photography
groups
where you can learn and and that's just
amazing jeremy started with a three
megapixel yep
i didn't really know that like a long
time yeah
well i know he was cheap but oh my gosh
now he's a friend of ours he's a
wonderful guy that's just too funny
i i did not know that part of the story
though that's amazing
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
still on baby step number one how'd you
guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit chministries.org budget
don't worry it's worth it
[Music]
christie wright ramsay personality is my
co-host today i'm dave ramsey this is
the ramsey show
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee i love this
guarantee i love this company these are
great guys
it means even if you mismeasure if you
mess up if you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your window blind for
free
wow you get free samples free shipping
and with the new promos they run
every month you'll save even more use
the promo code
ramsey to get the best possible deal
today's question comes from karen in
montana
i work from home full time and will be
selling my car to pay down debt
we will be a one car household for about
six months until we can pay cash for a
replacement
we are currently in a rural part of
montana due to my fiance traveling for
work and there are no towns within
walking distance
what are some side hustles i can do
remotely
i like this question um i'll tell you my
answer for karen is really for any of
you that are listening right now and you
want some extra money to pay down
debt or reach your financial goals my
advice is to start with what you have
your skills your strengths and your
stuff
your skills would be your education your
experience credentials certifications
anything you know and are trained to do
that knowledge that you have your
strengths are maybe things you're just
really good at
but you've never been officially trained
in it so man you're a really great
singer you could be a vocal coach or
you're a really great painter you could
paint sell paintings on etsy
whatever that looks like and then your
stuff do you have a computer you can
write a sewing machine you can sew a
swimming pool you can teach some lessons
when you start with what you have you
make it so much easier on yourself to
win and make money faster so my advice
to you karen in montana
even though it is a rural part of
montana if you start with what you have
and you structure your business
online whether that's online selling
products and services through
etsy or social media or a different
platform or
online through service based business
coaching consulting
something like that you can make money
from home and you're not limited
to a specific retail store front you're
not limited to foot traffic that type of
thing it just opens up
options for you start with what you have
your skills your strengths your stuff
and that will give you direction on what
a business idea
that would be good for you in your
specific situation
my friend dan miller who wrote a
best-selling book many years ago called
the
called 48 days to the work you love he
always said
um gather a bouquet of flowers from
those that are within reach
start with what you have that's what
you're saying and that's that makes a
lot of sense
i'm amazed that the number of people
that uh play the piano well and forget
they can give piano lessons or that
you know instead we have to go reinvent
the moon somewhere
online tutoring is yeah virtual
assistant
if you are if you are you know online
bookkeeping
uh it's amazing what you can do remotely
uh that's just task based right just
simple task based things so i don't know
we don't know what her career field is
she didn't say
but yeah that that's really that really
is the key
what christie was saying is to uh
gather the bouquet of flowers from those
that are within reach what do you have
skills stuff what was the third one
strengths and strengths
that you can use that's really good dan
is in portland oregon hi dan
welcome to the ramsey show hi gabe uh
thank you christy for taking my call
uh i live in a nice condo complex in
portland
and i sit on the hoa board about three
years ago
we had a stepdad
who is a kind of a prominent attorney in
the area decided to buy
one of the condos for his two
stepdaughters who
shortly thereafter decided to turn the
condo into a meth lab
oh god so
basically what occurred is about two
months before
hazmat and the drug interjection team
raided the location step dad did a
quick claim deed handing it over to the
two step-daughters
so now since then
the unit's been closed up we had the
locks changed on it
hazmat took the uh toxic chemicals
out of the location however they left
everything else in there
all the garbage the needles the syringes
i've got the pictures
it's horrific uh on the inside of this
condo and they're nice condos
so we've been trying to figure out how
do we go about
trying to get this unit cleaned up do we
take it out of our hoa funds
and clean it up and put it under a lien
uh and
can you go back on a quick plan deed and
challenge it
or um currently the the
courts are backed up on foreclosures and
uh
and putting it up for auction so we
figure it's another year or two before
it'll even come up for auction we don't
want to let this unit sit
and draw rats and and any other vermin
uh that may come in um it's about ten
thousand own and the property taxes six
thousand and the hoa uh fees that we
have a lien on
but we can't get the state or the city
to come in and clean it up
so uh do you know do you have any idea
what to owe on the condo
uh the skippy idp cash floor
okay and the two the the two brats are
in jail
uh not to be found they're gone
where are they i mean we need to find
nobody nobody knows
nobody knows we've had our attorney try
to locate him
and can't be found so talk to stepdad
um we have not talked to stepdad
because he did a quick plan deed that's
why i'm asking no i'm just trying to
find them i want
i just want to make them an offer and
buy the condo
so if we could go to them and say we'll
buy it for
20 000 yeah we'll give you money
and then i mean and you'd have to get
the i don't know if the condo
association
is authorized to do that with condo fees
i doubt it
uh you're not exactly authorized to
you're not you're a non-profit you're
not authorized to do investing on behalf
of the hoa
uh right but but um dude
something you gotta do something how
it's a condo worth if it didn't have all
this crap going on
so i bought my condo three years ago for
uh 225 and yeah they're going for
over 300. so scratch around find
somebody's got 40 grand and find these
brats and offer them 40 grand and then
let's clean and let the
investor clean the mess up you you don't
own the condo i i mean you're gonna have
to contact the attorney that represents
your hoa
but in my opinion you don't need to be
going in that thing at all
unless you have hoa documents that allow
you to break and enter
and clean up a mess and put a lien
against it on your on the behalf of the
hoa
i don't you could get yourself in a real
mess here plus it's dangerous
you don't want to you don't want to mess
with a dadgum meth lab man that's a
that's a
explosion looking for a place to happen
exactly exactly and even though they
took the toxic chemicals out
they left all the garbage and everything
that the
let me tell you if they baked meth in
there the toxic chemicals are not gone
they're in the wall
all right you're gonna have to strip
that thing down somebody's gonna strip
that thing down to the studs
if it was a house out in the country we
would throw dynamite in the middle of it
and call the fire department let them
practice on it
right it's a disaster to get that mess
out of there the fumes go into
everything it's baked into the walls now
it's a problem man i mean
somebody but if you can buy it for 50
grand spend another 100 on it
you're still in there way under as an
investor if you know what how to do the
recidivism work on the thing or the
that's not what it's called but anyway
clean the mess up
no and i'm talking about the baked in
mess it's like man it's
it's almost as bad as cat smell i mean
it's almost impossible to get it out of
there
so yeah you got wow i i would hesitate
to start
acting on behalf of the hoa without
legal counsel
right right and we're trying to figure
this out how do we get this thing
cleaned up
rather than let it set for two years
yeah i think you asked your lawyer about
that
but in the meantime for on a practical
level if you can get the ownership
transferred and get an investor to come
in
and clean the mess and do the full
hazmat strip down
on a meth lab good god and um
yeah it's i mean these things these
people die because the whole house
explodes sometimes is there a liability
on the condos on either side
it's potential i mean the hoa you know
has
they have uh the hoa would have
structural insurance on all the condos
but yeah it's it's uh it's a problem
yeah so i i would be looking for the
brats
and get you know offer them some money
with an investor in tow
and let that investor come in and clean
the mess up and
or meantime i'd be checking with my
lawyer that represents the hoa you need
legal counsel on this hoa be
careful because everything you walk in
there and touch i
have no idea what you're getting into
it's dangerous stuff
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today
corey is on the line in fargo north
dakota says on my screen corey you're
debt-free way to go
thank you dave it's an honor to talk to
you you too how much did you pay off
uh fifty five thousand dollars awesome
five five or six
five uh 55 55 000 and how long did that
take
uh 16 months good for you and your range
of income during that time
uh 55 000 a year okay what do you do for
a living
i'm a parts guy at a ford dealership
say that again i'm a parts guy
dealer parts guy what does parts guy
mean oh you work in the parks department
at the ford dealer
yep oh okay okay
that's okay good for you man your
phone's kind of breaking up we're having
trouble hearing you but that's okay
good for you man so what kind of debt
was the 55 000
everything dave it was uh a truckload
credit card
medical debt uh like you
name it student loans
good for you wow so how old are you
uh i'm 31 okay you're single
uh now i am okay
all right so you had all this debt and
you're 31 years old and 16 months ago
what happened that inspired you to get
out of debt
um i started a divorce that my wife had
taken care of the finances
all the time and i didn't realize what
kind of trouble we were in until
uh it all started raining down so you
ended up with all the dead or just part
of the debt from the divorce
uh just part of it
and uh and i decided that it was a time
for a change
and i was led to you by my sister
who gifted me a total money makeover
my goodness well way to go and 16 months
later
because it's all up to you you just
decide you're gonna live on nothing and
knock this out
you worked the plan yeah i worked
i worked your plan i i i sold
my truck bought something with cash uh
and just just got to it i found
everything i could get rid of got rid of
it
and uh yeah it was
it truly changes your life yeah way to
go i'm so proud of you how much did you
sell the truck for
uh i ended up with uh 8 000 in equity
that i just bought a new truck with
uh it was uh 26 grand
it was a 2016 f-150 it was my
dream dream truck i was gonna say did
you cry a little when that one left
uh that was emotionally like the hardest
thing to do
because as a guy your truck is your
identity yeah
well and you're at a ford dealer and
you're in fargo north dakota i mean
there's just so there's a lot going on
here there's a lot working against you
there
way to go man i'm proud of you that was
very brave yeah
very brave good stuff so how does it
feel especially with everything you've
gone through corey in the last few years
like to now be debt free and you've got
a
clean slate and a fresh start debt-free
how does it feel
it feels great like just
i feel like i could tackle a lot of
different goals right now and
i and i plan on doing that all right
wow good for making a better life for me
and my kids what do you tell people the
key to getting out of that is
just uh don't let your
emotions get in your way and make a plan
and stick to it
will you ever go back in debt now
uh no no i watched all right
well way to go corey very very proud of
you congratulations
i'm sorry you went through all this
trouble at home with the divorce and the
whole process but i'm very proud that
you cleaned this mess up and you've got
yourself a clean slate to
start forward with you can save up and
buy a move back up and truck as you go
along you're going to be just fine
you're going to make a lot of money in
your life
very very proud of you i've got a copy
of the legacy journey for you to say
congratulations that's your next uh
chapter in your story to
completely reset your legacy and then uh
of course another copy of the total
money makeover for you to give to
someone like someone gave it to you
and you can pay it forward because other
people are gonna be asking you how'd you
do that right
so good stuff man good stuff all right
cory in fargo north dakota 55
000 paid off in 16 months making 55 000
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two one i'm debt-free
[Applause]
way to go dude excellent job
very very well done very well done
lee is with us in ohio hi lee welcome to
the ramsey show
hi i just have a quick question
about refinancing my house okay
uh we are currently on an fha 30-year
with 5.25
we have 28 years left
and then last year we found you and we
became debt free
we have our emergency fund and we're on
baby step six way to go
wow good for you what do you owe on the
house
um 119 okay and are you planning to stay
there
yes good for you yes you need to
refinance is your credit bad
oh there's nothing on our credit good
okay get in touch with churchill
mortgage
what's the house worth do you think i
got 150 we got
a thing from our mortgage company today
and they kind of did some quick numbers
and told us that they could refinance
our house
to do an 18-year fixed rate
at 2.99 18 why not 15.
i had no idea it sounds like that's and
that sounds like that's an fha as well
is it
yeah she said was it fha streamlined
yeah
qualify for the conventional who doesn't
qualify for the conventional
we don't because we
own our own business and we have not
been in business for
two years and they need two years of tax
returns
she would be correct okay
so the streamline the streamline does
limit the difference in years it does
not allow you to drop down
more than so many years that's why
they're giving you the 18 years there's
guidelines on that
you're still probably will have pmi with
a streamline and it's a little bit
higher interest rate
should be zero closing costs though is
that what they quoted you
correct yeah did she wait could she wait
to do it until after she's been in
business a couple years would it be yeah
but i wouldn't because the five
percent's
so stinking high and we're dropping it
two percent saving two thousand dollars
a year
and we're knocking ten years off right
immediately plus you can
yeah i'm doing this it doesn't take any
money
and it's a cheaper rate and it's a
lesser year number of years
uh you you may even end up refinancing
it again later if rates
stay down but i doubt it i think you'll
probably just pay this one off
okay yeah i think they've i think they
offered you a good deal usually a
streamline
is higher this is also a very small loan
a lot of mortgage companies don't want
to ride alone this small so
a streamline is usually a higher
interest rate than market this is higher
but it's only slightly higher and that's
not a bad rate at all
yeah i'm taking that deal if i'm in your
shoes no closing costs
and you know you immediately are saving
two and a quarter two and three-quarter
percent
and you're dropping down ten years and
you can pay early on it there's nothing
that keeps you from doing that the only
downside is you're probably still going
to have that
the mip on it the mortgage insurance
premium so i think that's still going to
be with you
wow that's a good deal yeah so the
streamline
is fha to fha it's an fha program it's
not really
um that allows mortgage companies to do
this
and the reason there's no closing costs
is the interest rate is slightly higher
and they make their money off of that
difference
and that covers the closing costs okay
they can sell the loan at a premium
because the interest rate's at a premium
okay they can flip that loan back out of
that bank and make more
on it extra because of the higher
slightly higher interest rate
than the closing costs and then some
yeah so it's it's not a bad deal for her
at all though
just the same yeah just the same it's
worth doing and
getting out of that higher interest rate
loan and taking advantage of that even
with the baby business you got there
good stuff christy wright ramsey
personality is my co-host this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well if you've been paying attention to
the real estate market you've noticed
competition between
buyers out there it's pretty intense
inventory is really low
and it's driving prices up pretty
dramatically when inventories load
simply means there are more buyers
buying than sellers selling and it turns
out the pressure
turns the pressure up for everyone
buyers want to snag the right house
sellers want the right offer
this is not a time to play amateur hour
guys
low inventory is a big deal and to win
in this market you need a pro by your
side
that's why we find vet and endorse top
real estate agents across the country
called endorsed local providers to help
you
buy or sell our agents have years of
industry success
and refuse to compromise your financial
goals no matter how tough the
competition is
they're going to keep you in line with
common sense you can instantly connect
with an endorsed local provider in your
area go to ramsey solutions dot com
slash agent
you can find a ramsey trusted agent near
you
ramsey solutions.com slash
agent tracy is with us in memphis hi
tracy how are you
hi dave i'm doing well how are you
better than i deserve what's up
uh my husband and i have a rental
property in
south carolina that we would like to
sell
it currently has renters in it their
lease is up in december
and our property manager is telling us
that due to
covid the renters do not have to let
anyone
into the home so
for a personal health issue they have
decided they don't want anyone in the
house not even to take pictures so we
can post it online
so my husband and i were thinking about
talking to some of these
investment groups that keep calling and
want to buy our house
but we were hoping to get some wisdom on
that situation
before we started it because we haven't
done this
we never sold a home period so i think i
would go to an endorsed local provider
like i was just talking about
at ramsey solutions and find one of
those in their areas
i don't know anything about the current
status of covid restrictions in south
carolina
but i'm calling bs i was going to say is
that even legal
like can they even do that does your
lease not have the right to inspect the
property
uh i would have to read it i think
i think you have a wuss for a property
manager
okay but i do have the spiritual gift of
cynicism so
uh i might be wrong okay but i'm first
calling that because
i'm kind of like old school like if i
own a house i'd like to go in at any
time i want
within reason they have the right under
the law of what's called quiet enjoyment
meaning i don't get to harass
them but for them to stiff arm you call
covid
when there's not really a coveted
problem at their house
uh i'm just thinking this is a bunch of
crap so i think your elp
a good real estate agent who would have
an incentive to help you sell the house
could probably give you more accurate
information you may need to fire your
property manager
okay i just i that would make me
frustrated yeah i'm approaching it
approaching angry yeah
approaching angry you're a little more
gentle this hour
you know well i mean it would i'm just
trying to think i mean i wouldn't
now if they've got a sick child or the
the person's in chemo
or something then i'm gonna have a lot
of compassion and i'll back off of that
stance
but if they're just being butts and
using covid to be a butt
then i can help you with your butt
problem you know
i'll remove your butt right and so
that's a that's a possibility
uh i it just doesn't make sense i
i now it could be south carolina has
some crazy butt
you're just sticking with a theme here
with it yeah uh
but uh uh uh uh regulation on the books
right
it's possible yeah but i mean we we most
places had like
moratoriums on eviction last summer
for a while some areas have got link
more lengthy moratoriums of eviction
we had one in our area that lasted for i
don't know 90 days or something
and uh i had one tenant go crazy start
beating his wife and all this she had to
leave
i had to get him out of there because i
don't deal with people like that very
well
i don't have any tolerance for that kind
of white trash and so
um this expensive house
but anyway they they i couldn't get him
out because of stinking
coven moratorium on evicting people uh
but it had nothing to do with covet it
had to do with who's an idiot right
so uh but anyway you still idiots were
protected too
under it so uh but the that's that's the
kind of stuff runs through my head
tracy as a landlord for 30 years that uh
first and foremost now again i'm also
the other side of that is if someone is
in need we have the ability to be very
compassionate and very
slow and i'm certainly not trying to
bring harm to someone on the other hand
so i need more information about why
these people are stiff arming you
if i'm you and i need more information
about this law and i'm going to check
with an elp
and find that out because i think your
property manager is full of crap
i could be wrong now you people from
south carolina y'all can all write me
right now i'm going oh there's a law
dave you don't know what you're talking
about because
i don't know what i'm talking about i'm
just saying it
just smells like tenant misbehavior not
covid related
so yeah is there any element of the
property manager has no motivation
because they want to continue to manage
the property yeah
yeah or or they're one of these
companies that doesn't want to ruffle
any feathers
which really you shouldn't be in
property management if you don't want to
ruffle feathers because
it's kind of like the definition of
property management you ruffle feathers
for a living
you collect rent and you move renters
along that don't you know and
this is what you do right this is the
feather ruffling business right so
i feel like you're in a similar business
dave you just ruffle feathers on the
show all day every day
all right we're just gonna start that
that's our new that's our new thing
everybody do your fingers okay
oh the youtube people are the only ones
understand what we're talking about oh
my gosh
yeah the uh yeah yeah just cause a
ruckus
but i um no i don't think you have to
give the house away
my first step is not to give it away at
wholesale to an investor who doesn't
even need to see the inside
because what they're gonna do is buy the
house as cheap as they can
to cover the fact that they don't know
what's inside what they're getting into
are these people in there running a
crack house and you know they're going
to burn the thing down
or are they in there they got 73 cats
and you're gonna have to strip out the
plywood all the way down to this
joist because there's no getting a cat
smell out of a property
and so that kind of stuff i mean what
have you got in there what's going on
in there that they don't want you in
there or are they just trying to be hard
to get along with
because you know but you there there's a
limited thing depending on what your
lease says
and depending on what south carolina
actually has
as a regulation but i
i think you're onto something with the
property manager i really do i think
all shucks they won't let us in sorry
anyway
you see okay remember all those nine
million times people out there
that i tell you don't do long-distance
landlording
i've never heard you say that don't do
long-distance landlording remember that
that's it right there he says it every
day everyone every
time someone calls with the house out of
town i say don't do it that's it that's
the reason right there i don't know how
tracy got in this mess bless her heart
she's a sweet lady
and um those folks that are living there
are lucky they have tracy
yeah because i'm not as compassionate
unless i need to be compassionate and
then i can be compassionate but i'm
i'm just not going to be well and
there's an element too of this
aside from even if they do learn there's
stuff you got to do to get the house
ready to sell and not just take pictures
you got to make it
look presentable for well you can just
go in and start rehabbing a house with a
tenant in there that's not legal i mean
you have to wait till they leave to get
it ready but um
but for them zero access
yeah little well not in most states now
maybe in the
socialist republic of california or
something like that it's possible there
or maybe one of these other areas where
you know the laws are just wacky but
most states have
reasonable tenant protections and
reasonable owner
landlords right protections right and
there's a way that the law interfaces to
create
a fair transaction a fair
uh justice and mercy can be both
implemented there in a way where yes
compassion is available
but not if you're just misbehaving
within reason well hopefully an elp
will help her and then she can get it
sold and not have this long distance
rental and not have to deal with it
anymore there we go she said she's
getting on the market in december but
this is june
oh yeah yeah it's got a bit of a bit of
a waste
um yeah i'm wondering
if there's i'll start to get yeah that's
good
i think i think we got her on the run
there that's good that puts this hour of
the ramsey show
in the books christy wright my co-host
this hour
i am dave ramsey and we'll be back
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section
or head to the ramsay show.com thanks
for listening
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions
broadcasting from the dollar car rental
studios it's the ramsey show where debt
is dumb cash is king and the paid off
home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as
the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host christy wright ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author of the book business boutique
is my co-host today open phones at
triple eight
eight two five five two two five
ashley is in sacramento to start off
this hour hi ashley how are you
hi i'm good um so
dave i've become a single mom and i have
a
carmax vehicle appraisal for 45 thousand
dollars
and i'm still in a divorce process and
so i owe my husband
half and that leaves me 22
500 to spend on a used car of course i'm
not going to use that whole
amount and i need help making a decision
whether to sell it through tread
privately or trade in at carmax
or i don't know any anything you can
think of to help me
to make it easier would be great and i
do have young kids
so i said yeah i might not work i think
is the car paid off
yes it's paid off okay what other assets
are are being divvied up in the divorce
uh we have uh mutual funds
and we have the house sales proceeds
um how much and whatever's in the bank
uh well the calculation came to uh
recently came to i think i get like 12
000
after everything else
twelve thousand your part from the sale
of the house
yes what about the mutual funds
uh he went and divided uh
six out of sixty six thousand he he
decided to
transfer about 33 000 to uh
charles schwab account for me but it's
still a joint account so i that's still
being
um to be determined how
i don't know okay but
so that is the divorce decree final or
are you guys still in you're still in
mediation and negotiation
exactly the financial part of it anyways
yes
is what is in negotiation yeah it's
still
in negotiation it's been over a year
which i don't know why
taking so long so why do you need to
sell the car
now um that's what i want your advice
uh on because it's paid off and i i just
uh it's hot it's expensive for me to
maintain um
since i get oil change is like a hundred
dollars
i do get one more free oil change
it's a fairly new car i i don't think i
should rush into
uh training or anything did you say
you're working have you got a career
i've been a fellow mom for um
five six years six six and a half years
so and i i recently um
got a instacart job and uh to do on the
side
when my husband has a kid and i also do
uber
and list and go puff and you name it
for now it's temporary what's your
long-term plan on your career
i know i don't want uh to go into uh
school debt
and then i'm starting to wonder if i go
to trade school or something become a
surgical check um that
i don't know if i should do that because
i have such a young kid i have to find
a stable uh babysitting and i've been
working on that
what'd you do before you had kids did
you work
i did some computer work um and i did
like iphone repairs and just uh network
like computer network but it i you know
i had not done that for a long time
is that i i wanted to sort of steer away
from that but i
i'm going back and forth whether i
should just go back to that
you know what i what i used to do um and
well what you used to do didn't exist
anymore it's five years ago there's no
such thing anymore
um technology moves faster than that i'm
not saying you shouldn't go back into
technology but what you used to do
is not there what so uh go ahead well
i'll let dave speak to the money in the
car and all that but here i just want to
call out something i hear
in your voice ashley what i would love
to see you do is take
small steps of action that are going to
get your confidence up
so if it takes leaning on your previous
skills and computer work and now you're
going to look at being a virtual
assistant that you can do from home
during naps after your kids go to bed
after school pick up that's going to get
your confidence up i hear it in your
voice like you've been through the
ringer this last year
you've got all these looming decisions
that are overwhelming you i want you to
take small steps get quick wins that are
going to get your confidence up and help
you see
hey i can do this i can do this i am
doing this
i'm going to do this and so i just want
to encourage you whether that's
looking at the skills you had in the
past and exploring how to use those now
in a creative way through a side
business or
home-based business that's my advice to
you from the work
side and then i would i would find every
aspect of your life
to in this season while you're
overwhelmed make it as easy on you as
possible
what can you do to make your life as
easy on you as possible as you
as you walk this out and come out on the
other side through healing yeah
absolutely so have you got an attorney
obviously
she's so expensive i i owe her
i think um about nine thousand dollars
in debt
and i can't even let go of her services
until her tear off
so okay uh
you need to verify with one phone call
not a big long
hourly rate or something that how you
get those mutual funds that 33 000 out
of a joint account into just your name
it is i have access to it no you have
access to it
you said it was a joint account
yeah they don't want us moving any money
right now um
well he did and he moved it into an
account that still has his name on it
yeah he did and i don't know what
they're going to do about that
i i tried to take uh 9 000 out of the
mutual fund
to pay my lawyer so that way i can you
know let her go
and they i guess his lawyer made a huge
fit about it
and so i had to put all of that money
back into the mutual fund
the charles schwab
that's how serious they are so how are
they letting you sell the car then
uh it has to be written by my husband
and he did give me written
email um you know letting me know that
he he will allow me to sell it for
under these conditions but i still have
to give him half of it
yeah i know that and he but the mutual
fund is already your half
so i don't understand why if he took the
other half and you got half white still
has his name on it or is under his
control
it's uh not that it's under his control
except the courts have not made
a decision yet yeah so where'd the other
33 000
go uh he put it in a different
i think he put it in a different um
mutual fund company
i smell a rat so i'm worried about that
yes you need to sell the car at
and even if you do it at a carmax that's
fine and then get you a car
for about 10 000 and start working on
your career side what i was trying to do
is get you in control of some of this
money
which will give you some of that
confidence that christy was talking
about that's where i want you to head
towards
as fast as this ridiculous legal system
will allow you to do that
and get your attorney paid and move on
your way but you've got to create an
income going forward that's my big
concern for you right now
about a ten thousand dollar car is what
i would do if i were in your shoes
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt
no matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at eight eight two five five
two two five if there's one thing that
2020 taught us about investing
it's this you cannot invest alone you
absolutely need someone in your life who
knows the market
better than you and helps you make smart
decisions
not emotional ones look i love
do-it-yourselfers but diy
d-i-y-n investors well
i lack the experience to make good
investing decisions especially in a
global crisis
you invest in the wrong things you get
caught up in trends you make rookie
mistakes
you get greedy you get scared and you
build a
portfolio based on what you read on
reddit
and i gotta tell you 99.9
of what's on reddit shouldn't even be
read
so just help you with that period what a
black hole of nothingness
trust me you don't need to add any
unnecessary stress in your life
stop winging it get an investment pro in
your corner
like one of our smart vester pros
let 2020 be your wake-up call never
again let your retirement be at the
mercy
of a global crisis or your emotions
go to ramseysolutions.com smart vester
get a rock solid investing plan with
rock solid people
in your corner today this is the ramsey
show
kyle is with us in columbus ohio hey
kyle how are you
good dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
um so i have we're trying to decide how
we're going to be getting a lawsuit
settlement here in the next week or so
and i'm trying to decide what's the best
way to use it whether we should
you know take away whatever we think we
might owe the irs which i have no idea
what that would be
and then pay off what that we can with
it
or we are also planning on moving out of
state to either south carolina or
tennessee in the next
year and a half so we are also thinking
of trying to take that money
and put it into our house and we have an
opportunity to rent a house that's about
150
less than our mortgages right now and
then just sell our house now while the
market is hot
and get as much as we can for it and
then whatever we get from that
use that to pay off all of our debt that
way when we are ready to move
we can just pick up and go and then not
have to worry about the house
gotcha okay a lot going on with you so
uh what was the nature of the lawsuit
what happened
uh it was an employer discrimination
suit
okay and you're you guys were the
employee
yes and how much is coming
uh the settlement is for forty five
thousand and then i would have to pay
i believe nine thousand an attorney fees
and then whatever the irs
takes from it okay
uh well you need to see a tax pro on
this because it'll depend on whether
it's considered
punitive or compensatory meaning it's
compensation as to whether
whether it's taxed or how it's taxed so
and i'm not sure
uh all i know are though it's a
government office it's probably there
was no punitive
so i believe it would all be taxable
okay so it's probably taxable at your
standard rate
than uh your tax rate but talk to a tax
pro
don't just guess okay yeah but my guess
is
that you're probably gonna set aside
another nine or ten
for taxes okay that's my guess
uh because it would be net of attorney's
fees it wouldn't be
uh i think i think so i think you know
the
uh a fourth of the 36 would get you
there pretty close
so uh we'll set aside another nine for
that nine for the attorney
uh that puts us at 20 uh what 27
that you've got left over now how much
in repairs are due on the house and how
much debt do you have
uh the house is mostly cosmetic it's you
know carpet painting
uh deep cleaning stuff like that it's
mostly cosmetics
uh minus our mortgage probably around 70
to 80
and that includes student loans and
vehicle and credit cards
okay what's your smallest debt
and my student loans are probably about
four to six thousand maybe
maybe four thousand and we have credit
cards that are smaller than that but
in general enough they're more than that
and how much do you owe on the cars
uh probably about 15 to 20
and then the other car maybe a couple of
thousands okay and what's your household
income
uh probably about 105.
and and what is your house worth between
me and my husband if you fix the house
what's it worth
we just refinanced like six to eight
months ago and it was appraised at 180
but the houses in our neighborhood right
now because of the market
are have sold for no less than 215. okay
all right and what do you owe
uh probably around 140. okay
all right so yeah i'm with you let's fix
the house and sell it and pay off all
your debt
okay but that's what we're leaning
towards let me tell you the hole in your
whole plan
you're guessing at all your numbers you
don't know a
single number you don't even know your
income
everything's kind of another couple of
dollars everything's sort of close
i don't know i don't know you need to
get exact bids on the rehab
don't spend 30 but yeah 10 makes sense
but exact bids run a project here run a
budget
and then you need exact bids on all of
your debt now when you
sell your house and you and you become
100 debt free paying off everything
which you should have enough to do that
with the extra
17 000 you've got on this too then
you have to change your habits
for the rest of your life so you have to
cut up your stupid credit cards
tonight i am more than willing it's
getting the other half to do all that
well
then don't sell your house and pay off
the debt because if you sell your house
and pay off the debt and you don't
change your habits you're going to be
right back in debt
and this whole exercise was for nothing
i know we haven't been using a credit
card he just does he's
uncomfortable not having anything i'm
uncomfortable with how stupid you all
have handled money
i am very much also
we have been trying to dig ourselves out
of this hole for the last 10 years and
we had a very small shovel
yeah well no you have a 105 000 shovel
you've not put much effort towards the
digging
well that's accumulated in the last year
or two the bigger
we have significantly raised our wages
in the last
two years yeah so here's the thing okay
you don't know your numbers and he's not
serious
you guys are gonna mess this up if you
don't change your your
your spirit on how you're approaching
this i i don't care it's not gonna
affect me
you do whatever you want but this advice
might be bad advice
if you don't change your spirit if he
doesn't say i'm chopping up the credit
cards
we're going to get on a budget we're
never coming back here again because you
just gave up your house for a stupid car
and some credit cards
all the all that equity it made me think
of uh dave i you know i went to the
university of central florida in orlando
in my last
semester there so this was first
semester of my sophomore year i did
terrible in school
i wasn't focused and i got bad grades
well when i transferred to ut knoxville
they took my credits but my gpa started
over and i was
so grateful you got a do-over i was so
grateful
i busted it and got a 4.0 you've got to
care you've got to see this
for what it is yeah it's a fresh start
clean slate
if you if not you'll mess it up again
and you'll be in the same boat but not
have a house to bail you out the next
time
i did not know that's why your gpa was
fought i didn't know you not no your
fabulous gpa was a false
it was not false i earned it i just
earned it
a year no you didn't i earned it
sophomore year youtube
senior year it's not an accumulation of
all your grades
it's accumulation of two and a half
years yeah well the thing is it
you did learn your lesson and you didn't
start over so good good yeah good
metaphor yeah yeah we'll discuss the
other part later yeah
hey hey i got the piece of paper that
proves it i got it
that's the story i'm sticking to it you
know what and we didn't even ask your
gpa when we hired you so
you don't care
get your work done oh that's fun
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today i'm dave ramsey your host
thank you for joining us
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five scott is in tampa florida
hey scott how are you i'm well dave how
you doing
better than i deserve what's up
so so i i just had a really quick
question for you i've been listening
since 2018
i didn't know it but i was on the dave
ramsey plan to get debt free but
didn't have the right mindset so thank
you for that um
so over the last i don't know 10-15
years
you know i've had different jobs and a
401k here
and i rolled it into annuity which was a
bad idea um
that has now been transferred to another
uh traditional ira
so what i have now is
um my nest egg if you will
divided among three different locations
my question is whether or not
that should be one place or it's okay to
be three
it's not the end of the world i like all
of them i have all
of my mutual fund investments uh with
one financial advisor
now there's a different account numbers
i have many many different accounts from
different events that have gone on
you know every time you roll over a 401k
to an ira that creates a different
account you can't combine those
and so you know i moved to sep one time
and then i changed it to a roth and
you know and so i've done some moves
like that so i've got multiple accounts
but they're all with one advisor
and that's just by choice you just yeah
yeah because you're here
two benefits i get of that one is my
three benefits one is my wife knows
where all the money is if i die
okay she calls one guy uh two
uh i get a consolidated statement of all
those different
uh uh accounts and i don't have to try
to pull them together myself i can just
look down at the email
click on it it opens up and there it all
is right
real simple and and three uh
you know my investment at uh uh
directives and that particular smart
investor pro that handles my personal
stuff
and i are in a line so i don't have to
think about
one account as being managed by someone
that thinks differently than i do i've
got
one guy that thinks like i think we're
in agreement we're in alignment
and so it's very very smooth and he can
call me up and go hey there's this going
on
maybe you want to do this and i went
yeah that's a good idea let's do it and
that kind of stuff and they'll remind me
once a year to do my
backdoor roths and uh all those kinds of
things so it's just a
it's a a streamlining of
information of values of location
there's not any technical mathematical
advantage to that
if you had three accounts
with one advisor and they were in the
exact same thing that they're in with
three different advisors you're going to
make exactly the same money
unless the advisor is charging you
differently in some way
but other than that there's not any big
big savings
with that but now if you've got like
for instance let's say you have a
certain mutual fund company fidelity or
american or something like that
and you've got them with two different
advisors you may not be getting your
break points that you deserve on your
commissions and your fees
because once you get above 50 000
there's a break point you get above 100
000 there's another one above a half
million there's another one
and you start saving money but they
might not be showing them as
consolidated
under your name because there were three
different people you might be overpaying
fees
that way but it wouldn't be a huge
chance of that happening it's likely
that they've pulled them together but
maybe they haven't you know so i just
use one just because it's very clean
i don't have seven different insurance
guys i got one insurance guy zander
he handles all my insurance i was
emailing him at the break just to make
sure i had a car i just bought i got to
get it covered and so
that kind of stuff and i don't have to i
don't have seven different people i deal
with on that
um uh you know if i can help it
um now but anyway that's just the
the cleanliness is like you have your
your little own
uh advisory group that your real estate
person
one real estate person one insurance
person one tax person one
lawyer general family law a state law
uh the different things like that so you
build a kind of a group around you to
manage the
the the wealth it's just more convenient
like you said less to deal with less to
think about of all the people you've got
to go to you've got one guy
got one person that can help you with it
so yeah i would think it would just take
some of the headache out of it
yep william is with us in oklahoma city
hi william how are you
hello i'm doing well how are you better
than i deserve how can i help
thanks i was going to call and get your
opinion on um
on if you think that i would be better
off to stay at my current
um job or pursue another um
another option staying within the same
field
um i am a dentist and i currently work
at a
government public health
type clinic and i would be looking to
possibly
go out to the private practice sector
well my guess is in the private sector
you would make a lot more money is that
correct
there is the potential too yes what do
you make now
uh around gross around 150.
okay yeah there's definitely potential
to make more than that as a dentist in
private practice assuming you grow your
practice and
i mean you might not the first year it
might take a few years have you got an
opportunity to join a practice
i do and the dentist that i went to
growing up who actually did
shadowing hours to get into dental
school and i go and work out at
his office a couple times a month
it would be his practice that i would
that i would purchase
oh you would purchase a practice yes
okay so what's it making
um the production is about 1.2
million a year and the collection is
about 98
so it's pretty close to that what's the
profit
um the profits i
i don't know i'm not into that
for that level of it yet well you need
to be because i mean if you made a
million two in gross revenues and you
spent a million three to do it it's
probably not a good idea
yes so the the gross revenue is
interesting
but only to the extent it creates profit
so
let's find out what he's spending to get
that and what he's netting
i'll give you a guess that he's pulling
a half million a year out of that
would you guess that um
yeah at least yeah
i think the overhead is typically in the
range of about 35 percent
yeah i was just i may be a little low
then but yeah somewhere in there so
what's he want for the practice
um the initial um we haven't
done like any type of um consulting
or whatever for it yet but initial would
be around a half million
if it's profiting a half a million a
year and you can buy it for a half a
million
what i would do is work for free for a
year almost and pay him off in one year
and that's a deal yeah that's a deal
why is he selling it so cheap
um i think basically it's just because
it's
me my whole life yeah it's like like a
little nostalgia he wants to leave it
leave his baby with someone that he
trusts pass it down yeah
kind of mentorship yeah let me just tell
you dude it might be worth four times
that
okay uh whatever the net is after
everybody's been paid
it's probably worth about 4x that and so
half a million on the surface here we're
i'm guessing at the net and you are too
but i'm going to guess and say that
that's what's known as a bargain right
there
uh if it's you know top line of a
million too that that's
that's the deal i suspect i could be
wrong but i i i
and yes i think you should do that and
leave 150 000 behind
here's the other thing william and i
will say why would you not do it
well i'm i'm pretty it's kind of one of
those things where it's uh
it's pretty a comfortable yeah job
position that i'm
in right now and it's as feels as safe
as possible
you know yeah here's one thing i'll say
william uh read on trade leadership read
all the business books you can if you do
this you're not just a dentist anymore
you need to learn how to run a business
and that's different
i've talked to a lot of dentists that
are broke because they don't know how to
run a business
learn how to run a business if you do
this and you'll you'll do we've got a
bunch of them in entree leadership elite
and in the
advisory groups in our small business
stuff that'll help you you probably
ought to check that out for sure that's
a good point christy
yeah and hey man yeah you need to do
[Music]
this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day proverbs 2 6
and 7 for the lord grants wisdom
from his mouth come knowledge and
understanding he grants a treasure of
common sense to the honest
he is a shield to those who walk with
integrity
robert schuler said never underestimate
your problem or your ability
to deal with it this is true
open phones this hour i'm dave ramsey
your host christy wright ramsey
personality is
my co-host it is a free call at triple
eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight
eight two five five two two five
hunter is with us in idaho falls idaho
hi hunter how are you
good how are you better than i deserve
how can i help
yeah so uh just to kind of jump into
this
my wife and i are about 80 000 in debt
our current take-home pay is 83
k um we were looking into selling our
house to possibly pay off the debt
uh we've talked to realtors we currently
owe 205k
and they're telling us that we could
sell it for 300.
um which one of your thoughts on if that
was a good idea or not
so you owe 80 000 in debt on what
so most of it student loans um it's
about 55 000.
we have a car that's 16 000 and then we
did some home repairs
and that's the rest of the month that's
about 14.
okay and uh what's your household income
take home is 83 000.
do you like your home
yeah we like it um it's not a forever
home like
no home is a forever home
heaven is your forever home i guess
that's true
uh yeah we were planning on maybe
building in maybe
five or six years depending on how fast
we can get out of debt
so so the hot real estate market kind of
got your attention and you're thinking
it's an easy way out of debt
correct okay
uh no i wouldn't sell it
i'd roll up my sleeves and get on beans
and rice rice and beans it's gonna take
you a little over two years
uh you're gonna live on nothing uh you
might even sell the car i don't know but
you're gonna go crazy here
and clear up 80 000 worth of debt
with the money you make you can do that
let's say you did 40 a year for two
years that'd be living on nothing
and you'd be debt-free in two years so
it's between a two and a three year get
out of debt plan you're probably working
extra
you're probably selling some stuff you
may be selling that car
uh you may have some savings that's not
retirement savings set aside that you
didn't mention to me
that you could use to throw at this and
accelerate it
that's what i would do i wouldn't sell
your house because i think your house is
going to continue to go up in value
and you're going to you may you know you
don't want to step out of this housing
market unless you're stepping right back
into this housing market
because it's crazy out there if you step
out it's going to be you know and you
wait two years it may be hard to get in
it
it will be harder it's not impossible
but it'll be harder to get in
and so i um you know the problem
the great news is in this market you can
sell a house for a lot of money the bad
news is you buy another house for a lot
of money
uh and so it doesn't no i i think you
keep this house
and i think you roll up your sleeves and
get really really aggressive don't you
yeah it's interesting because there's no
other motivation
to sell it other than the debt they want
they're living there now they're they're
fine you know what i mean it's not like
oh we need to move anyway for a job or
something there's no
there's no life transition that calls
for this other than just wanting to
speed up the debt process
well in this hot market gets your
attention and you get saying oh i could
get out of debt yeah right that's well
no i think you need to get out of debt
but i don't think this is now yeah
stephanie's in jefferson city missouri
hi stephanie welcome to the ramsey show
thank you how are you guys better than i
deserve what's up
that's awesome well i um have been
talking to my mom recently and i feel
like i'm in a good place with money and
i'm actually kind of at a loss on
what to do with our extra income um
i know like it's such a good place to be
in but i'm just i
will give you an address maybe it's a
dave's cabo fun
right i know it's great so i just want
to tell you we do have a mortgage of
about a hundred and ten thousand
um i actually paid off our house about
two years ago um but then we bought the
connecting
land next to us um hence why we have a
mortgage again
because it's part of our mortgage plan
now okay how much do you have in savings
um well right now i have about sixty
thousand dollars
and then we actually sold four acres of
that and are making seventy thousand
dollars
okay so you're going to be you're going
to pay off the land then
completely i do have a car loan but i
could clearly pay that off i mean it's
zero percent interest which i know how
you feel about that yeah pay it today
so i can pay it any time today
okay i will do it i will do it so i
maxed out my roth i own my own business
so i maxed out my ross
i maxed out a roth from my husband i'm
also going to max out
a step which is 25 of my income
my husband also has a pension hopefully
he will have a pension
in 25 years you know that's the goal um
and so i just i does he have a 401k
available at his work
he does but they don't contribute
anything it's literally just through his
company which is why i did the roth
house
but i mean if you're if you're
completely debt free you still want to
max out his 401k
because it keeps the government's hands
off the money especially if it's a roth
you want to do it can you do a roth 401k
at his place
i would have to ask so i need to look
into a raw 401k so i can do
just a traditional like a roth you can
do a traditional 401k or a roth
ira 401k whatever they have available
i'd do roth if you can get it
in the mutual fund types that we talk
about and then you load your for
you roll those load those roth iras and
you load that sep
now we've kept the government's hands
off of as much of your money as we
possibly can because your baby steps
seven at this point
right way to go and so like is there
anything do you recommend
any other investing accounts i mean if
i'm i'm a hairdresser and i'm one
i love my job but do i want to stand for
10 hours a day when i'm 55.
so my goal is that i can retire early
now will i
maybe i don't know but i don't know yeah
i think just the the wealth gives you
options
we don't have to call it retirement but
it gives you options
you could buy you could buy the salon
and sit behind the desk
right so do you think the sep the 25
of my income going into my step and then
my roth and his roth are maxed out i
mean is that enough what i'm doing
i mean i can't do more you're not going
to be able to access yeah but you're not
able to access any of that until 59 and
a half
okay so keep doing what i'm doing so
keep doing what you're doing max out his
401k and then if you've even got more
that's the money that would bridge you
between 55
and 59. that money would be just a
traditional mutual fund with your
smartvestor pro they can help you invest
it
in what's called a low turnover mutual
fund where the taxes aren't activated
until you pull it
much and um you know there's all kinds
of stuff you're going to be able to do
at baby step 7. make sure you're sitting
down with the smartvestor pro
and let them start teaching you about
what all is available to you guys
okay and you know i i'm kind of got
myself in trouble i have
only one ross with edward jones but it's
my brother-in-law and i don't know how
to get out of
that so i'm like i don't love that he
knows all my business
uh what i would do is go over you know
jump online to a smart vester pro
and uh and if you like the smartvestor
pro after you meet with them and you
feel comfortable and they've got the
heart of a teacher like we say they do
and you want to move your accounts over
there i think you can just tell your
brother-in-law i'm
uncomfortable uh and i
i you know it's just a boundaries thing
with me i'm uncomfortable
yeah and so i i've got to have a guy
that's that's a little more arm's length
and i know you'll understand that
besides that my roth's not that big a
deal
right right and just blow it off and you
know it
depends i don't know how classy he is
but he'll probably get over it
yeah definitely well and i did buy your
book the um
legacy yeah thank you well i think
you're on your path here she's
impressive and i love that she's content
what else can i do and that's awesome
and what else can i do
that's right so good good stuff good
stuff
well thanks to ben hill our producer and
of filling in for
james childs who's doing something else
and uh kelly daniel our associate
producer and phone screener i'm dave
ramsey your host
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
you